Almira over to you
oh sorry over to you welcome back to the
studio it gives uh yes sir a chance to
powder his nose welcome Alexandra
congratulations with uh what a victory
first of all uh please tell me a little
bit about your preparation and
especially the depths of your
preparation how far did you know the
position and the plants
well I mean I might be mistaken but I
think hampi never played Knight F6 uh at
all I mean she preferred the Italian
and D5 it's out of curiosity this
morning I asked myself well I knew that
there is such a light and I started
analyzing it you know I always blame
myself because at some point I start
analyzing lines that
should never I mean happen in the game
but I spent so much time and then I
don't have time for like the main lines
and that's what happened today but
apparently I mean everyone seems to try
to surprise me I mean that started in
Nicosia I couldn't guess a single line
but here I was just lucky very lucky
because this morning I just you know
decided to like um uh what's this line
just yeah and I uh I didn't of course
have time uh to like analyze it very
deeply but I saw that it's a very
pleasant end game so Bishop B3 now yeah
here it's like seems to be
um
like a trendy move uh because Bishop B5
was played in the game between videot
was playing with lucky I think ESPN
Cavite and even though Andrea won uh
black was fine after the opening so
Bishop B3 uh isipenka played then after
this game in some World Blitz I think
and
um I think he didn't capture B6 so
that's the line goes it's quite forced
uh Bishop C5 he is here and I think he
played
um Bishop F4 or something like this or
at least I might be mistaken but a
bishop takes B6 that's what I was
planning to play no that was another
game I'm talking about the game
yesterday
in the world Blitz maybe it's not uh so
this is a novel to Bishop B6 and is this
a new uh concept well maybe I mean again
I haven't analyzed it deeply I just saw
that the engine gives a small plus and
as uh said to myself okay it's such such
a pleasant end game you know you're not
really at risk of anything and you can
just play for two results which is very
very nice and it's the first game it's
still jet lag so and
um I mean I've had so much trouble with
my wide games in Nicosia just a week ago
so play it safe with white I mean I like
this idea and I was very happy about the
outcome of the opening
um but then yeah but then I was not sure
about 94. I mean I thought maybe I
should have played Knight F1 with the
same idea because it seems that she has
to play Rook uh E8 and then I can play
Knight G3 transposing to the game
because uh yeah after night before she
could have taken on e4 and then Rook
takes E4 and a rook E8
h2e8
yeah and even though I can take on E8
she has to take with the King because of
Bishop A4 but it's so I mean
rookie one king D7 I mean it's so close
to this opposite colored Bishop even
yeah I was looking at Bishop D5 during
the game because she was thinking for a
very long time but okay Rook A7 and of
course it's a very very pleasant end
game for uh wide but is it like uh
winning I was not sure and I was a
little bit I mean mad at myself that I
didn't play Knight F1 and I was very
relieved when she played Rook h28 so we
kind of transposed to this uh Knight G3
Bishop G6 position there's such a lovely
position already an age three age four
H5 yeah yeah H4 and I was sure that she
was going to play H5
and I was not sure what to do here
because I was thinking about taking on
E8 and playing Rook D1 but still I
thought that she must play H5 okay and
let's have a look at the end of the game
where like very nice yes it was uh well
study like and I know how much you like
the status so let's have a look uh where
that's like it started I don't know and
then here yes yeah
and I think Bishop C5 was a very
important mistake well when I played C3
I mean I a sold this line and I thought
that Bishop C5 should not be possible of
course I didn't see why but somehow you
know this little
um like domination and all those
tactical motifs they just I mean
well you just have this feeling that it
shouldn't work you should be winning but
since time travel was approaching I
repeated the moves yes were you
hesitating here the did you were you
choosing between the move Bishop E6
after Knight A7 let's say uh Bishop B6
no I didn't see I didn't consider Bishop
six so you were always calculating
before no A4 as well instead of Bishop
A4 I mean when I was going to this
position I thought that A4 also seems to
be very nice but I didn't say anything
after Bishop F7 and
um even though I mean my position seems
to be very nice but it's not like a
fourth line anymore and in the game I
mean I thought that she has to play 94
uh King to G6 and 84 King 36 but then I
F5 exactly Bishop takes D4 I capture on
G6 Rook F2
uh King GH3
right yeah King E5 and I take on G4
or I played G7 on King D5 or uh okay
well yeah but you can play King C5 for
king or whatever and I thought that I
can always capture on D4 and play G7 and
I was so happy that I saw this line and
I said to myself okay it should be
winning but then she played Knight D5 a
king D5 she surprised me but again I
just have this feeling that the king is
okay you have to activate your kink in
the end game but this not this one
position this is such a beautiful
position Alexandra uh we don't have much
time today I still have one more
question for you which was actually
important because you won so many
tournaments and I think what touched me
the most after uh you won the World Cup
you said that this Victory doesn't have
exactly the same flavor as when I won
the World Championship when I was
younger so could you explain this well
when you get older I mean you don't have
such an energy anymore you don't have
such a motivation anymore I mean you you
lack many things of course you're like
getting experience with everything but
you know this experience you just forget
lines and forget your own gifts it's
just been too too many and it's like
every new tournament I mean every New
Year it's it's already quite an
achievement because you kind of force
yourself to go on and to work to fight
to like I mean stand up after uh defeats
but victories or they are so sweet at
this point because you don't I mean you
don't play for Victors anymore you just
play you know to go on to continue to
enjoy the game to create some
masterpieces once in a while and if you
happen to win and it's such a relief and
it's such a pleasure you can never
compare like a victory when you're
almost 40 and victory when you I do and
you're just supposed to win and here you
know that anything can happen so it's
well well it's a masterpiece indeed
thank you Alexandra well uh
well we wish you a lot of luck for the
tournament and well to savor the victory
you know tonight thank you thank you so
congratulations as well uh Alexandria a
very important